you remember Margaret Ferrier she was an
SMP MP and back in September 2020 caused
pandemic restrictions she tested
positive for covid and proceeded to not
isolate but get on a train from London
where she was working as MP back to
Glasgow this is Margaret Ferrier there
and she also had lunch went to church
despite having covered symptoms now she
was actually convicted in court of
recklessly exposing the public to the
virus and given community service and
the SMP withdrew the whip from her so
she is now an independent now
interesting development she's been
investigated also by the standards
commissioner in the Commons and a
recommendation has that that
commissioner asks the a committee of MPS
to look at his investigation and
recommend a sanction and that today
we've got a sanction of recommended of
30 days now if that goes ahead that's a
pretty tough sanction it means that
there could be a by-election in her
constituency of Rother Glenn and West
Hamilton and that is a seat that labor
held only five years ago so potentially
a difficult by-election for the SMP just
after having their new first Minister
it's also very notable that on the
committee of MPS it's seven MPS and
seven lay members they were asked to
vote on whether to impose this a 30-day
sanction and the conservative members
did not want to vote for it the four
conservatives who incidentally are also
the same for who questioned Boris
Johnson the other day at the Privileges
committee so the first time ever the
standards committee was split we'll try
and find out more about why that split
happened but the majority of these
standards committee recommended a 30-day
suspension MPS will then have to vote on
that but opens up the possibility of a
potentially very interesting by-election
in that Scottish seat in a few months
time she's already been
disciplined by the police hasn't she she
has she got 270 hours of community
service in a court in Glasgow last year
and this investigation started just
after that finish now of course she
can't stand for the SMP at the next
election because the whip has been
withdrawn but of course she may appeal
this because there's probably going to
be 18 months until the next election so
she may try and stay in place
it seems like a very large sanction 30
days it is a tough sanction but of
course she has committed a crime and
been convicted in court although she
didn't get a prison sentence and Nicola
sturgeon who was then the leader of the
SMP said at the time that this happened
that she should resign she should go
immediately so she has defied Nicholas
sturgeon in staying on this long staying
on through Court proceedings but now it
seems that her MP colleagues have given
her a tough enough sanction she may have
to fight a by-election it may well be
that at that stage she says well I'm not
going to because she can't of course be
the SMP candidate and she may just then
choose to give up